how are you dawn have you done reading
oh my gosh better for talking to you
yeah appreciate I hear you guys talking
a little basketball I like I've been
watching this draft it's what what these
kids it's fun - what - the thing go down
so are you or are you a Pacers fan being
from Indiana dawn was that it's not what
you would say or more as the Celtics guy
because a bird and what happened out
there but you know obviously you follow
the Pacers just a little bit but more
the Celtics than anyone obviously the
Lakers a little bit with magic in that
that whole back-and-forth was a funnier
to watch
mm-hmm I love it how are you Ben I know
we spoke the other day about your event
in December which I'd love to I'd love
to be at for sure dawn yeah let's talk
about your charity a little bit here
I'll give you the floor on what work you
do in the state of Indiana Don well you
know it you know kind of just looking at
this you know you guys are talking
basketball a little bit and watching the
draft and the emotions of these kids and
and really I think that kind of goes to
what we do we want to give kids in the
toughest areas chances and that's with
chances to make good decisions and
that's with computer labs summer reading
programs safe places to go after school
where they can continue to grow and get
mentored and that's really what we're
all about is kids more than anything and
giving kids with that that don't get the
opportunity a lot of us you know for up
with I grew up in a great family great
home atmosphere that all has that
advantage to make good decisions and you
just want to give these kids the chance
to make good decisions
yeah Mattingly charities org is how
people can get involved with with you
and your and your charity work Marin
Mattingly charities org all right Don um
I just want to go down memory lane a
little bit with you here the reason why
honestly the reason why I loved you and
and watching you and so many people who
are
my age just still get emotional when
when you are ever mentioned or see it
it's just the way that you comported
yourself and went about your business in
a time when the Yankees weren't weren't
really very good and I'm wondering how
how you view your days when I was one of
those guys rooting for every single time
you step to the plate Don I look at it
as as great times obviously having a
chance to go to the big leagues and
really grateful for the area that I came
up in with you know Lou Piniella rich
Gossage Willie Randolph they win so it
got to play with these guys that kind of
taught you how to be a pro and what it's
like to play
grateful for New York it was a perfect
place for me you know kind of a
small-town guy but I didn't have to be
loud or anything else was able to go out
and just play and you get plenty of
attention in New York for just playing
you didn't have to go be a big
personality or anything like that and
that was I think the perfect situation
for me what about Matt Steinbrenner Don
what about him and telling you cut your
hair and shave and all that stuff well
obviously with with mr. Steinbrenner and
New York you don't really get out of
there alive right you're going to those
going to be some some rocky roads but I
always look back to the positives of
that for mr. Steinbrenner the one thing
he want to do is win he that was his
goal and I you know for the fans for the
players until you appreciate that and so
you did there are times when you know
he's going to get on in the papers a
little bit you got to deal with that but
I still look back at it as a real
positive you knows my career ended I
remember having needing back surgery and
he was the first guy that he said is
playing for me got me in New York
he wanted me to see the best doctor you
know so that's the kind of things you
don't hear about with him but the kind
of things that he would do for his guys
men home running who
against Seattle in Yankee Stadium done
and that in that playoff series in 1995
which was I do believe your last home
run in Yankee Stadium I I will never
forget it what in the world was I liking
it finally playing in the playoffs
for the Yankees in the old Yankee
Stadium hitting a home run what was that
like for you
rounding the bases oh that was a great
feeling
honestly that playoff was you know a lot
of fighting to get in and you know and
kind of my era that was the first year
the wild-card and we were able to get in
as a wild-card team after years I mean
every years we went 98 games don't get
the playoffs and and you you're fighting
to get in and so I knew my career was
coming to an end and to get that
opportunity to play in postseason you
know that was crazy yeah been at home
alright
you know I remember it well it's a good
st. Dennis who's also from Evansville
this was kind of weird you know you're
playing in the playoffs and in a huge
game you're playing the guys from your
hometown so there was more at stake than
just the playoffs that was like a
hometown pride thing going on - there
was no chance you playing in 96 Donna
Bleus Lee that was when Tori came and we
know Tino Martinez arrived but there was
no chance he you sticking around and
playing and being part of those teams
that that don't know you know a lot of
people talked about I really was
thinking about retirement I was seven I
was really struggling with my kids were
at an age where they were playing ball
and they were back in Indiana we tried
the the New York thing it didn't work
very well for our kids and really my
situation there and I was really
struggling with a battle between my kids
growing up playing ball and they were
coming to New York near as much just
because they wanted to be playing Little
League and they wanted to be moving on
so I as the 94 season unfolded I really
felt like that I had I had another year
left my contract but I thought 94 was
going to be my last year and then the
strike happened and the season ended we
didn't get in I knew that I couldn't let
that be the last year from 95 really
I kind of knew the whole time that was
it it was more of a family decision a
lot of people said oh you're back and
it's an that I kind of figured out the
back finally it took me a while to
figure it out after all the problems I
was having and it but I knew the family
thing we shake was tough for me cuz even
when I was at home in New York I felt
like I was on the road and I knew it was
time I know what to won the World Series
in 1994 Donald Arthur Mattingly who
would have won that World Series in 94
yes you know my like one of our coaches
and he said my jaw would want to say
yeah the Expos were great too with
Felipe Alou and and Tim you know he was
mentioned Wallach they were great too
but come on they were about four teams I
think Cleveland's who thinks they would
have wanted that's the one they would
have won so you know there was three or
four places but for us it was it was
really fulfilling 94 because we'd turned
the corner I went through some had some
really good teams early on went through
about a three-year stretch there where
we went backwards and we're trying to
rebuild Showalter came in and had us
turned around we picked up some good
guys like in Paul O'Neill came we got
David Cone we had Jack McDowell he
started putting the pieces together and
we knew all those kids were coming in GE
and Pettit was there Bernie was there so
the foundation was coming but it was
just an it it was fun to be able to turn
that corner and see the lights be in the
center after going through some really
rough year well done I appreciate the
call man I know you're you're in the
grind and you got lots going on but you
know everybody around these parts know
what you mean to me personally as you
know I
you met my you met uh you met my kids
when you were here is the skipper of the
Dodgers you were there the day I threw
on my first pitch I think that was your
your team that day when I threw out my
first pitch and my kids were here and
you met my wife who was again who was
pregnant with my daughter and we told
you what my daughter's middle name was
going to be all right all right
you know reach them seriously this is
it's always humbling when people would
do something like them and I'm I say
that yeah
so honored when people do that starting
off with dogs you know and it's nice to
see some you know I've met some kids in
the recent years that families the name
their kids after you it really is
humbling experience yeah my daughter
Taylor Mattingly Eisen which is also
great because her initials are tme too
much isin which is true as well done it
kind of works all around
hey Don thanks for the call really
appreciate it you are the man and
anybody who knows you would say that so
for sure alright good to talk to you and
and well I'll talk to you actually I'll
get in touch with the next couple days
Don that's for sure you bet that's Don
Mattingly good luck against the Phillies
and beyond that's the manager of the
Miami Marlins for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app